in jQuery the enemy method performs a
custom animation of a set of CSS
properties this method changes an
element from one state to another with
CSS Styles the CSS property value is
changed gradually to create an animated
effect only numeric values can be
animated such as margin being 30 pixels
a string values cannot be animated such
as when you're setting the background
color to blue or red or something like
that so here's the basic syntax here so
first you're gonna have your element
selection and then it's going to be dot
animate and then you're gonna pass in
your properties your CSS properties that
you want to change and then there's
three optional things you can pass in
the duration easing and complete that's
just a callback function that it calls
when the animation is complete and
there's also another syntax this one
where you pass in the properties just
like before and then you pass in the
options this is just a JavaScript object
you pass in with various key value pairs
for different options this just allows
you to have a little more control than
the first method because there's a lot
of different options you can pass in
almost all the options have to do with
calling a callback function at various
points in the animation if you want more
information about the options you can
use for that you can check the link in
the description so let's look at this
example down here well first of all on
our page we just have the the run button
and the hello div block and then I just
have some basic CSS and here to style
things our JavaScript down here we're
going to select the the go button and
we're going to add a click function so
on click it's gonna run this function
here now inside the function we are
going to select the block which is that
the hello block and we're gonna run dot
animate the first thing we pass in is
the properties we have some key value
pairs that show the CSS properties we're
going to animate over the course of the
animation it's going to put all these
CSS properties to this value so it
starts at opacity 100% but we're going
to set it to 50%
so it's going to start at a hundred
percent and gradually go to 50 percent
here margin left now just so you know on
CSS will be margin - left but in jQuery
you take off the - and then you
capitalize the first letter of the
second word so you can see we use a
slightly different thing instead of
margin left 50 its margin left + equals
50 so it's just going to add 50 pixels
to whatever the margin already was for
the opacity it's always gonna go to 50%
and then height it's also going to go to
a specific thing 400 pixels and then the
next item you pass in is the duration so
I passed in 3000 that's 3,000
milliseconds or 3 seconds then we pass
an easing easing is either gonna be
swing or linear swing is the default so
if you don't pass in anything here it'll
just be swing or linear so linear just
moved at a constant rate swing kind of
eases in a little bit to the beginning
and the ending and then that complete
that's the callback function we're gonna
add at the end which we are going to
select this which is the div block that
we're animating and after that we're
going to add another HTML code when I
add this animation complete div so let's
see what this is gonna look like hit the
Run button and you can see the opacity
changes the margin left changes the
height changes and then the animation
complete runs at the bottom now let's
see what happens when I hit the Run
button again so as you can see the
opacity did not change the height did
not change what the margin left changed
where I press the Run button again
that's because we have this plus equals
50 so it just adds 50 to whatever the
value was but the other values are just
set so it's not going to change those
things and you can see it add the
animation complete div at the end
against there's two of them now I'm
going to take off this easing one so
it's gonna default to swing so let's see
what that looks like it's just a little
different so you can see just at the
beginning and ending of the animations
of little
now I'm just gonna actually change this
animation to show you how you can chain
animations so I'm just gonna get rid of
all this and then I'm gonna do dot
animate we're gonna set the width to 90%
I'm just gonna copy this and then paste
it a few times we're gonna change the
font size so now you can see I've
changed these animations so we're going
to change the width then the font size
then the border let left width let's see
what that looks like so you can see it
ran one animation after the other when
you just chained them by adding dot
animate and then putting the next
animation there and obviously within
each animation you can animate more than
one property but this is just an example
with one property okay that's the basics
of the dot animate method in jQuery
again check the link in the descriptions
for the other options you can use to
pass in which are mainly about different
callback functions you can use at
various points of animation my name is
Bo Carnes thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good